okay let's talk about Fox News's Laura
Ingraham you might recall that Fox News
host Laura Ingraham took what sort of
seemed like an abrupt vacation after
about a dozen of her advertisers stopped
buying ads on her show as a result of
her comments about david hog david hog
is a student from the parkland Florida
high school that suffered a mass
shooting a few weeks ago and david hog
himself after laura ingraham did this
called for a boycott of her show an
advertiser boycott of her show on
twitter and on a dozen or more a really
dozens of companies that were
advertising on her program and before
her abrupt vacation about a dozen of
those companies had already bailed and
then she very very quickly announced
that she was taking a week off for
Easter it's possible that that week off
was pre-planned and it just wasn't
mentioned it might not have been the
timing of it was pretty weird but she
did return right that was part of the
question because when Bill O'Reilly
ultimately lost his program on Fox News
he took a very sudden week or two off
was it a week or two I don't remember
and very quickly thereafter the show
went away but Laura Ingraham did come
back but not too good news and in fact
the number of advertisers dropping her
show increased from 12 to 20 by the time
she was back for her first post Easter
break show on Monday and that's at least
20 advertisers that have dropped her
show that we know about and the latest
one here is Allstate Insurance the
difference seems to be that Allstate is
kind of being more subtle so there are
companies that when they decided to drop
advertising with Laura Ingraham they
tweeted about it they put out a press
release about it they made it known that
they were pulling ads and if media
reached out to them to say are you
pulling ads they would say yes Allstate
is taking a bit of a different approach
they've not been answering questions
they were asked to confirm that they
pulled ads and they said we've taken
note of your concerns which isn't an
answer
all to the question of are you still
answering advertising on the program
they were asked are more ads scheduled
to run on laura ingraham show and
allstate said we cannot answer that
question so they might be taking the
more subtle approach which is they're
dropping the ads but they're not making
noise about it
Ace Hardware took that approach men's
clothing store Joseph a bank said listen
we were never actually buying on laura
ingraham show we were buying generally
on Fox News but Joseph a bank ads have
sort of mysteriously or not so
mysteriously disappeared from laura
ingraham show as well and i'm kind of
mixed about this the the subtle strategy
the subtle strategy of pulling the ads
because on the one hand I like the idea
of just pulling the ads quietly not
making a big hubbub for publicity and
just saying we're just not going to fund
the program anymore but it can also be
sort of a calculated thing right because
you might say well pull the ads the
people that are paying close attention
to who's advertising will notice it and
they'll reward you they'll be happy
right the people who are on the sort of
the side of David hog but by subtly
pulling the ads without making an actual
announcement about it maybe the people
that would boycott you for pulling the
ads won't notice because you're not
drawing attention to it in any case the
pulling of the ads is a good thing and
there there's still people saying these
are limits on free speech this is a form
of censorship it's just such a bogus
perspective and a misunderstanding of
what censorship and free speech really
are I was actually talking yesterday
about this with Stamp seed or host of
the majority report it's good not to
fund propaganda it's good not to fund
people who criticize students at high
schools that suffered mass shootings
right it is objectively good and people
will say to me but David you could be
hurt by that same sword that's a double
edged sword if I support the boycotts by
advertisers of other programs to the
point that those programs could go out
of business I also could be the [ __ ]
of the same type of advertiser boycott
listen if I say something that is so
upsetting to people and so disturbing
and so horrible that my audience
activates or people not in my audience
and go to advertisers and say look at
what David said pull your money if I'm
saying despicable things then the case
can be made that I deserve to be
boycotted and that my speech has
consequences and my speech having
consequences is not the same as some
kind of blanket censorship or
restriction on free speech and people
will remind me of YouTube's ad pocalypse
that was not a targeted boycott of me
for the things I said it was horrible
and I am completely against what
happened and everybody knows the extent
to which it hurt the program during 2017
but that was something that happened to
cross news and politics it happened to
conservatives and liberals and it was
about advertisers becoming sort of
skittish about having their ads appear
on edgy content or controversial content
that is completely different than me
saying something and then that speech
having consequences and advertisers are
free to make the choice about where to
support me whether to support me or not
we have a good relationship with the
advertisers that we have and who would
it who would I be to say you can't
decide on the basis of my content
whether or not to keep advertising so
good luck convincing it to the fans of
Laura Ingraham this has nothing to do
with censorship this has nothing to do
with free speech this has to do with
companies with a profit motive making
decisions using whatever barometer they
have whatever rubric they have to decide
where do we advertise and where don't we
advertise and I'm glad that 20 or more
advertisers are saying we're not going
to advertise with Laura Ingraham anymore
give us a like on Facebook facebook.com
slash David Pakman show we will take a
quick break and be back with more after
this we've talked about how more and
more Republicans have been opting to
retire and not seek reelection rather
than risk being taken out maybe by a
Democrat
maybe by a non-trump affiliated
republican and this is all as a result
of the damage that Trump has done to the
Republican Party we've seen a number of
Republicans say they're not going to run
for re-election this morning we learned
that this phenomena goes all the way to
the very very top because Republican
Speaker of the House Paul Ryan the third
in command in the United States
political hierarchy is not running for
re-election and of course Ryan is
telling a very very positive story
saying he's leaving Republicans in good
hands he's had 20 years it's a good run
he wants to spend more time with his
kids but this is not like the beautiful
riding into the sunset that Paul Ryan is
trying to portray and there is every
indication here that there is major may
Anik in the Republican Party and the
decision even surprised many Republicans
that Paul Ryan wasn't going to be
running for reelection as soon as Paul
Ryan announced which was broken earlier
today Republican congressman Dennis Ross
of Florida also said he is going to be
retiring and Speaker of the House is
just not a position you bail on if it
appears that you've got sort of a clear
sailing path to maintain it and that
doesn't mean that Paul Ryan's
explanations aren't valid right I'm sure
he wants to spend more time with his
family
I think his daughter was like an early
teenager when he became Speaker of the
House and you know I totally get it
right he wants to spend time with his
family he has been in there 20 years but
most people would decide to stick it out
just a little bit longer if they have a
clear opportunity to make it another
couple of years in a position of such
power and it isn't even clear that
Republicans are going to maintain the
house at all never mind Paul Ryan in his
specific seat and if they did maintain
control of the house in the midterm
election would it be a productive
context for such a beleaguered to borrow
a word from Trump a beleaguered Speaker
of the House in the sense that many
trumpets aren't loving what Paul Ryan
has been doing been doing it's gonna be
a very interesting midterm and actually
I don't know if you've been following
the iron stash of Bryce
Randy Bryce Randy Bryce is a Democrat
who's
against Paul Ryan in his district in
Wisconsin it was understandably sort of
a longshot candidacy Bryce was building
momentum and he has growing name
recognition within within the district
but running now rather than against Paul
Ryan running against or in an open seat
election in Wisconsin is a very very
different scenario and if you're in
Wisconsin and you're thinking about
getting involved in a race there it
would be an amazing victory to not only
take out a Republican seat but the one
previously held by the Speaker of the
House the retiring Speaker of the House
and bring that back to Democratic
control so we'll be watching that
particular race I will also be watching
sort of the ripple effect over the next
two or three weeks of more Republicans
saying you know I want to be with family
or I want to move on to private law
practice or become a lobbyist or
whatever the case may be
I would predict in the next two to three
two to four weeks you're going to see
even more Republicans sort of put their
finger in the wind and feel the
direction that things are going and join
Paul Ryan in this and and as I mentioned
trumpets might not actually be upset
that Paul Ryan isn't running for
re-election because many of them see
Ryan as a sort of non Trump friendly
force in the Republican Party so I think
many of them would actually cheer it
send me your thoughts what do you think
that Paul Ryan's retirement resignation
call it what you will means about the
2018 midterm elections and even more
broadly sort of about the future of the
Trump presidency I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman and the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show I have some news that
might be shocking to a lot of people in
our audience if I say the number ninety
seven percent and climate change a lot
of people in our audience know that that
refers to the supposed consensus in our
scientific community that human actions
on our planet are causing climate change
and this is a number that's very often
cited we have a ton of science around
this number we have a ton of studies
that defend this number there's 97%
consensus and I have what might be very
very surprising news for many people in
our audience today
which is that I'm ready to come clean
and admit that the 97% number is flawed
it's just it's not an accurate number I
don't want to call it fake news because
that's giving them a win on the language
which I don't want to do but it's in an
incorrect number and if you're a climate
science denier and you're starting to
feel aroused and titillated by what I'm
saying I want to encourage you to keep
your clothes on just for a second
because it's not that 97% is too high it
actually is drastically low it appears
that the real consensus over recent
history on human influence of our
climate is 99.94% not 97% and this is
based on a new meta-analysis that looked
at more than 50,000 peer-reviewed
climate change articles from 91 to 2015
and it's not 97% consensus it's 99.94%
and even that number might be too low
because if you look at not 91 - 2015 but
just like the last few years it appears
to be 99.99 percent consensus that human
activities on our planet are influencing
the climate and one of the major
problems is that belief in the science
is extremely politicized and if you look
at a recent Gallup survey which asked
people basically three questions are you
worried about climate change do you know
that there's a scientific consensus and
do you believe that humans are causing
it Democrats overwhelmingly believe that
those three things are true right 85 to
90 percent of Democrats are worried they
believe that there is a scientific
consensus and they believe that humans
are influencing the climate on the other
hand only 35 to 42 percent of
Republicans are either aware of or
concerned about or believe that humans
are influencing the climate so this gets
us to what I call informational
incongruity ok I've talked about this
before
this this is something that the audience
seems to react very positively to
because it identifies what I think is a
major problem level one is like we know
about an issue we agree that it's an
important issue but we just disagree on
our position is different right so like
abortion abortion is a political issue
we could debate whether it's resolved
based on roe v wade but we have
significant disagreement about what the
policy should be on abortion a level ii
disagreement would be we generally know
about the issue but we disagree how
important it is so like before same-sex
marriage went national as a result of
the Supreme Court decision most people
were aware of the controversy over
same-sex marriage but some people just
didn't really care about it as an issue
they didn't think it was anything we
needed to deal with like listen it's
just not legal in some places and that's
good and I don't care about that level
three is a lot of people don't know
about the issue level three
informational incongruity that's like
Fox News viewers who might have no idea
that there's a major investigation into
what took place between Trump and Russia
we can't even debate the merits of it we
can't even debate the importance of it
because some people aren't even aware
that it is going on and on climate
change that's kind of the direction that
things are going you don't even have a
majority of Republicans realizing that a
scientific consensus exists so number
one I don't think anyone's going to be
influenced because the real number is
ninety-nine point nine four versus
ninety seven because if you already
trusted the 97% number you're not going
to change your position because it's now
ninety-nine point nine four and if you
weren't aware of that number or believed
that it's fake anyway you also don't
care if it goes from 97 to 99 so I
actually don't know how we can really
get beyond this and start figuring out
what to do about the climate science
issue but the numbers are stunning and
at this point completely undeniable and
I'm curious whether you've experienced
these sort of Sciences your religion
people there's people who will write in
to me unless a David you're doubting
science in a faith-based way the same
way that people tell religion and I have
to explain that people will hold on a
second science has built in self
correction mechanisms and in fact in
science people are encouraged there are
major rewards for people who can poke
holes in what are the accepted
scientific consensus consensus consensus
is I don't know what the plural is you
can win a Nobel Prize
if you debunk the consensus on science
where do you see that in religion you
just don't you just don't but I think
the religion
connection is actually closer to
politics because there are people doing
politics as religion and I think it's
bleeding into science because what you
find is like you said there's die-hard
Republicans that as part of their
Republican identity sure are saying that
this science is just it's bunk it's all
a green conspiracy that's a political
religion it really has nothing to do
with the science the thing that gives me
a lot of hope is that when you look at
the presidential elections when you talk
about hardcore Republicans year after
year after year it's about 25 percent of
us so most of us don't fall into that
category seventy-five percent of us
either look at this consensus and go
like yeah it's real or you have the
people in the middle that either don't
know don't care a lot of people it's not
really about climate science so one of
the things that I do on my show is
because that's controversial I talk more
about the pollution because the solution
is the same right not burning fossil
fuels yep so there's ways for us to get
to solutions without having to deal with
the political religions I think one of
them is just taking the 25 percent and
be like you're religious about this we
can't really talk I prefer to talk to
the 50 percent that aren't voting that
are in the middle that just don't know
what to do with this whole situation and
then the people that are already sold
the vast majority of it yeah that is
something I talked about which is you
actually don't need to convince the
outliers and the extremists in order to
win elections because we have 50% voter
turnout in this country and president
Trump conceivably could win re-election
based on a combination of low voter
turnout and our electoral vote system
with an approval in there in the 20s
right in the high 20s you can actually
still win a presidential election
because people don't vote if the vote
out to george w bush yeah if the voter
turnout went even just from roughly 50
to even something like 62 percent you
completely marginalized the ability of
those extremists who have these religion
and the religions go beyond the sort of
political religion I think is an
interesting term because you see those
dogmatic beliefs around
constitutionalism
and constitutional originalism the idea
of the Constitution effectively as a
sacred text similar to the Bible or the
Koran or whatever else you see it with
this what I call strict father morality
strict father
morality is the dogmatic idea that I
claim to want to reduce abortion if I am
a right-winger and then someone comes to
me and says we know how to do it
comprehensive sex education and ready
access to contraceptives I'm against
that if I'm a right-wing conservative
because you are not actually behaving in
the correct way if you have unprotected
protected sex non-procreative sex you
deserve the consequences almost like a
strict father saying if you do it you
should get pregnant and you should be
forced to carry the baby to a full term
and give birth to it that is a dogmatic
idea fundamentally it's not a pragmatic
idea where we actually know what works
to reduce the number of abortions right
and I think it applies even beyond
climate change there's a lot of these
pseudo religious dogmatic ideas the
other one is the free market right that
exists on the right this this sort of
religious approach to the free market we
uh I don't actually think that just
because we agree to the consensus
doesn't guarantee what the policy should
be and I think that that scares some
people on the right certainly the
reduction in fossil fuel use is sort of
an obvious one but I think that there's
just a lot of people on the right who
are scared to admit that they are aware
of the consensus or just agree with the
consensus because they believe that it
definitely means I don't know no more
SUVs or whatever it is there's still a
debate to be had over what the policy
should be although I think as you
pointed out the direction that the
policy should go is pretty obvious at
this point it is and I actually I I
don't even agree necessarily the people
on the right are against reducing fossil
fuels not because of all yeah because
when you actually talk to people I mean
there are plenty of conservative reasons
why you should switch to renewable
energy absolutely you know there's
people that are for wind in fact um I'm
researching electric cars right now and
one of the people that is rumored to
have saved the tax credits is Senator
Chuck Grassley of Iowa yeah and you
can't get more Republican than him but
he's into wind energy and the economics
of it makes sense sure so I don't think
it's necessarily and just out in the
world there are plenty of people that I
know that are Republicans but are
driving electric cars that do care about
this that know the science but that's
that's one of the problems I have with
just like dividing people in the left
and right because my own father he's
knowing that I talked about him but my
own dad was a Republican on when I was
growing up he counts himself as a
libertarian now he drives an electric
car he is singing the praises of it he
volunteered at an aquarium for years you
know he's really into environmentalism
people just don't really fit very well
into these boxes and when it comes to
fossil fuels what I'm witnessing is that
our Congress which makes the laws is far
more extreme yeah then most of the
country on most issues that's true and
that else has a lot to do with the
broader issues of how politics are
financed and a lot of other stuff yeah
totally over the weekend there was a
horrible incident involving a fire at
Trump Tower in New York City that led to
a death and the story has lessons not
only about sort of the moral depravity
of the guy in the Oval Office which
isn't news at this point but also about
cronyism and regulation and a lot of
other important areas and as the story
goes a fire broke out at Trump Tower
Saturday it killed an art dealer named
Todd rassner in his 50th floor condo the
condo did not have sprinklers this is
the second fire at Trump Tower this year
there was a small one on the roof of the
building in January and it turns out
that Donald Trump actually fought
sprinkler legislation in New York City
which would have required that this
building be fully sprinklered because
new buildings already have that
requirement in New York City same thing
here in Boston and that arguably would
have prevented this death and in 1998
after a couple of fatal fires in New
York City then Mayor Rudy Giuliani was
pushing for mandating land lors
landlords to retrofit sprinklers into
their buildings and Trump and lots of
other big real estate developers it
wasn't just Trump doing this they all
didn't want to spend the money that it
would cost to retrofit their buildings
with sprinklers they were grandfathered
in in the law that was eventually signed
and didn't have to do it and the law
said ok old buildings are grandfathered
in new buildings have to have sprinklers
and of course Republicans are saying
listen Trump was a Democrat back then
you can't really blame him for doing
that or this isn't unique to Trump I
agree that this wasn't at all unique to
Trump but I think the more interesting
story here is the regulation piece right
there's this idea from some on the right
that you don't actually need to pass
legal regulation because businesses in
the free Mars
get have an incentive to just regulate
themselves blah blah blah insert
free-market sort of dogma here we know
that that doesn't happen right we know
that that doesn't happen because we saw
the sugar plant where someone died in a
mountain of sugar after there was not a
safety device put in that regulations
were pushed for and we have endless
examples of this and I feel like if
there's any lesson here it's not Trump
is a bad guy we learned that a long time
ago it's not business people like to
save money it's that the idea that
there's this sort of self-regulating
method in the free market of business
where no one would ever do anything bad
because then it would be bad for their
business it just doesn't happen it
doesn't happen and we need regulation
and it's abundantly clear well in this
example how many Trump towers are there
like if you want andris that were made
on the fiftieth story how many options
do you have New York City I guess dozens
I don't know I guess and this particular
example makes me so angry because I just
watched there's a new documentary on
Netflix about Donald Trump it's a four
part I can't remember the name it's
something from yeah but in it they
talked about when he was building Trump
Tower yeah and the enormous tax cut that
he got to build Trump Tower so when the
city goes and regulates something for
safety of the people who bought those
cheaply designed and you know they
weren't used the worst materials they
had the lady that constructed him she
was appalled by it but for the safety of
these people they that moved in there
but pay those taxes that he didn't have
to pay for him to skip this safety
measure yeah especially being the
president United States after the ground
fault our incident it's just infuriating
to me it's like if you get these tax
credits from the city of New York you
should have to follow their laws and
there should be no grandfather sure yeah
wellness and that's not again that's not
unique to Trump of course yeah uh
and as usual Trump responding and what
is the worst possible way right someone
died here and Trump went on Twitter and
rather than I don't know offering like a
condolence for the fact that someone
died Trump tweeted fire at Trump Tower
is out very confined well-built building
well-built building which of course was
only as well-built as it is because of
the regulations that were in place
otherwise
Trump would have cut either more corners
right were even more corners were it not
for the regulations that governed how
this building was built aside from not
having sprinklers it would have been an
even worse building Pat well I like that
he put fire men and fire women oh yes
job it's very gender area galas have we
got that well absolutely also this is
just a weird detail but Trump reportedly
referred to the guy that died once as a
crazy Jew which again I mean none of
these each one of these details in
another presidency would have warranted
like a longer period of discussion
it's an aside that Trump once allegedly
referred to the guy's a crazy Jew yeah
we don't even have anything to add
because it's just completely expected
that there would be some kind of ad
hominem like that let's take a break
give us a like on Facebook at
facebook.com slash David Pakman show
back after this in what sounds like a
completely made-up story that is sadly
very very real Republican South Carolina
representative Ralph Norman pulled out a
loaded gun during a meeting about
preventing gun violence over the weekend
and he specifically pulled it out I mean
it's just the logic of it is so bizarre
to show the people that were in the room
just how much safer everybody is because
of the presence of that gun and also
that the gun just sitting inert on a
tabletop is not going to fire itself and
he also reportedly left it out the
entire rest of the meeting which in some
states would actually be the crime of
brandishing a firearm I think where you
live in California they have a pretty
strong brandishing a firearm law South
Carolina this is perfectly legal almost
welcomed in some ways the image I have
in my mind is straight up mafia like
like you someone comes in and says they
need to talk to you and they take the
gun out and they put it on the table
they don't necessarily mention like I
could maybe use the gun on you but it's
there in the corner of your eye the
whole time they were telling you what it
is that they want you to do and Norman
isn't denying this he said that he did
it he said to the Post and Courier he
did it to illustrate that guns don't
shoot people people shoot people which
of course most reasonable people get
that in principle guns don't
spontaneously discharge other than those
Remington rifles the story which we
covered a couple months ago which is a
horrible story but generally speaking
other than the guns that do fire
themselves most guns don't fire
themselves but the point
of that phrase is really lost on me
because the real problem is that ready
access to very powerful guns drastically
increases the killing power of the
people with the guns and I don't know if
that's a talking point you deal with
often maybe not if and if not you're
lucky because of where you live but guns
don't kill people people kill people to
me seem it's so ridiculous that it
sometimes becomes hard to even argue
against in a way well I mean where I
live I'm I'm living just outside of
Oakland yeah and people are using guns
to kill people all the time sure and so
when I go on because I have radar season
tickets and we have tons of metal
detectors but as we're going into the
stadium I'm constantly thinking of the
fact that if someone had a high-powered
rifle and we're going through the
security line yeah they can mow down a
bunch of us in fact I go in first
quarter most of the time just they don't
want to be in that situation because I'm
aware that people have guns around me I
never feel safer because of that fact I
feel safer inside the stadium after I
know that everyone's gone through metal
detector sure so just the idea that this
guy's pulling it out and he's like this
is for your safety I instantly would
have felt less safe just knowing it was
there but now the the counter-argument
though would be wouldn't you feel safer
in the sort of staging area to go in to
the Raiders stadium if it wasn't
presumably a gun-free zone and you knew
everybody was armed because then no
shooter would be stupid enough to show
up there and shoot anybody right no
there are people packing heat in that
parking lot all the time we all know it
so that's already situation it's not a
gun-free zone out in the parking lot
where we tailgate all the time like no
there's guns everywhere yeah we're aware
of it and the only thing that concerns
me is if someone does go and hide in the
plants first of all hiding in the plants
there's gonna be some people killed
before we even know where the guy is
yeah well what are we gonna do have
everyone in the line pull out their guns
and now we have crossfire like I don't
want to get hit by the crossfire that's
why I mean we've talked about this
before Pat like when you actually
analyze so many of the shootings where
people say well it took place where guns
aren't allowed the Aurora movie theater
shooting for example how would a handful
of armed people in the dark movie
theater have sort of improved the
situation because immediately the gun
shots are reverberating you don't know
who the good guy with the gun is or the
bad guy with the gun it's dark anyway
police eventually show up now you've got
five people with guns through the police
know who the right person is to target
and when you actually apply it and this
is where I think the right actually does
have an advantage structurally on a lot
of these issues the idea is sort of
simple and concise and very neat like
listen you put more guns into place it's
hardening it as a target people might be
dissuaded from from coming in and doing
a shooting because they'll know that
other people will have guns in practice
when you think about it it doesn't make
any sense yeah and also saying that it's
not guns that kill people it's people
who kill people you're very simplistic
you can put that on a bumper stickers
so it's just good political messaging
going down a list of like oh with
there's you know this contingent or this
contingent that could lead to someone
getting shot it's not getting shot you
lose the ones it's not gonna work do you
ever deal with that how like for example
hey abortion is murder so abortion
should be illegal it's just such a nice
neat concise argument and like the the
left-wing position is not the opposite
of that it's nuanced then requires like
five minutes to lay out and I think that
that is really actually puts progressive
ideas at a disadvantage merely because
they need more explanation in a sense I
mean yeah it's everything is more
nuanced than so many of these things
make it and even with the the gun thing
that whole idea rests upon the fact that
people don't want to die themselves how
many of these shooters walk out of there
alive oh you know that they're not going
to this this YouTube crazy yeah like she
shot herself right so that's the thing
if you're going in to basically fire
like die by cops suicide by cop I guess
what they call it if that's your goal
anyway you're just trying to take out as
many as you can so it's the gun gives
them the ability to do that absolutely
in a way that knives and pills don't yep
and we have seen that we mean it's it's
it's been seen that to happen that way
so many times that it's kind of almost
just disgusting at this point to even
have to say here's a hundred examples
that we have of where it happened in
exactly this way